got a cake we're gonna cut it now if
there was two of us as there are this is
quite simple you're just one person cuts
the other person cheese it's almost
unfair
no one's envious perfect way to cut a
cake a lot trickier though when you have
three people we've got three people
Alice Bob and Charlie and they're gonna
share this cake and we want to make sure
that it's as fair as possible and at the
end nobody is envious of anybody else's
cake turns out there's a very good way
to do this that's actually quite
recently discovered and I'm gonna try
and talk you through it so ass goes
first and Alice gets to cut the cake
into three pieces that she feels are
equal so she would be happy with any of
those three pieces oh gosh okay I'm
gonna go there things I've got gout jail
free card cuz it's a fruitcake so I can
just claim that there's more fruit in
one side you know that was what I was
aiming for it's not bad oh okay I think
I can see the Dead face which one for
dead pink sparkly bits on there yeah
absolutely there's I mean there's more
to a cake than just sighs some people
like this sort of crusty bit around the
outside some people like the sugary bits
some people you know hate the fruits
there's it's your personal preference
that comes into this as well okay
so Alice has cut the cake into three
pieces where she wouldn't mind which of
those three pieces she got now it's
Bob's turn so Bob gets to pick which he
thinks are his two favorite pieces now
either said that that one wants the
rubbish beef so let's kind of leave that
one to one side and a theme that Bob
goes for one of these two but Bob from
those two says which he thinks is the
best piece of all let's imagine that Bob
thinks this bits the best there now what
Bob has do he gets the knife now and Bob
gets to cut a little trimming off of his
favorite piece until his favorite piece
is now equally as good as his second
favorite piece right so that little
trimming kind of goes to one side there
so now Bob doesn't mind between getting
this one or this one it's fine he's
happy with either of those Alice is sort
of sitting 2-1 signs desperately waiting
for them to hurry up so she comes okay
charlie is no Charlie's go Charlie gets
pick which piece of cake he wants to eat
can
which everyone's so Charlie might pick
one of the pieces that hasn't been
trimmed or he might pick the piece which
has been trimmed whatever piece he picks
let's say he picked this one here it's
now gonna be Bob's turn to choose a
slice of cake if Charlie didn't take the
trimmed piece Bob's gonna want it
because he's already said that that's
his top you know in his top two joint
top so Bob's gonna take that piece so
now Bob's happy
Charlie's definitely happy they got
first choice Bob's definitely happy cuz
that was his equal top two and now Alice
ends up with this piece and she's
definitely gonna be happy too because
she cut the cake in the first place and
she cut it in a way that she thought
that all three pieces were equally fair
so that's fine right so that's the
majority of the cake sorted now we have
to deal with this trimming no that's
wasteful Brady no because Charlie went
last on the first main cake cutting
section Charlie now gets to go first on
this day so Charlie gets to cut this
trimming into three pieces so that he
thinks that each piece is equally as
good as the others okay now once he's
done now now Bob gets to pick which of
those pieces he wants say Bob goes for
this one here now bob is definitely
happy because he's got his number one
choice out of the trimmings and we
already know that he's happy with his
main chunk of cake
now it's Alice's go and whichever one
Alice picks she's definitely gonna be
happy because in the very beginning she
thought that all three of the pieces of
cake were equally good she's ended up
with one that hadn't been trimmed off
and now she's got an extra bit so
there's she's definitely gonna be happy
and then finally Charlie ends up with
the last still trimming and he's
definitely gonna be happy too because he
cut the trimmings in a way that he
thought that they were all equal so
there you go that is envy free totally
fair and totally delicious cake there is
actually an end person version of this
algorithm the only thing is the number
of cuts that it takes to get this sort
of envy free solution gets bit bonkers
yeah so what do we start getting
trimmings of trimming trimmings of
jimmies the trimmings the tribunes
journeys to extremes so in general the
number of cuts that it takes to divide a
cake between n people fairly is n to the
N to the N to the N to the N to the M
yeah there's kind of bonkers
you are never aware of how much noise
your body makes until you are satisfied
phone with you know headphones sort of
looping yourself back up you know into
your ears
what do you mean like a grumbly tummy
atomic my god you never notice how Gumby
your tummy is when you're in an audience
it's like roaring in your ears
continually if you don't listen to
audiobooks it is something you should
try and you should go to audible.com
slash numberphile because audible have
the best range of audio books out there
and if you sign up for their 30-day
trial using that URL on the screen you
can download a free book you can start
off with a free one and I'm going to
recommend well this is a physical copy
but I'm gonna recommend the audiobook of
this one which is cold the mathematics
of love patterns proofs and the search
for the ultimate equation see like that
whatever early writing going on there
the mathematics of love and it's oh it's
by you and the reason I'm talking about
now is because not only did Hannah write
this book but she recorded the audiobook
version of it and I want to quickly talk
to her about that because I've never met
someone before who's done this the one
that you feel really self-conscious
about is it's really kind of a bit gross
actually
but like the sort of the sound of that
your mouth makes no wet noise yeah
exactly so it's sort of almost like
clicking it's still way that your saliva
moves around in your mouth so there are
a few tricks that they have to try and
minimize it one of them is to make you
eat green apples you kind of sat in this
audio but if eating green apples Jenna
let me reduce the clicking sound when
you're also not allowed to have milk or
chocolate before you do it you can't
have a milk or chocolate before you
record and you have green apples with
you yeah I know we're talking makes a
bit too mucousy so when I have you ever
listened back to your audiobook like
have you gotten it it's like someone
pouring honey in your ear so if you
would like to have honey poured in your
ears by Hannah
then can I recommend you go to
audible.com slash numberphile 30 day
trial and audible you can you can
download any book
you're free one but I'm gonna recommend
the honey in your ears that is the
mathematics of love by Hanna Frey
we haven't actually said what the books
about because I've been so fascinated by
oh yeah and it's obvious what it's about
it's all about like how mathematics
applies to things like dating and
relationships and stuff like yeah yeah
exactly how to use maths to make your
own love my have a little bit more
efficient and is is quite a good book
I have read it and I have listened to it
honey you can see milk